[Música]
llegamos directo a panamá ahí está
nuestro corresponsal oscar sulbarán ah
porque hoy llega la primera dama de eeuu
silva y den a ese país esto como parte
de su gira por américa latina oscar muy
buen día un gusto saludarlos nuevamente
le pregunto en qué se centrará la visita
de la primera dama y cuál es su agenda
en panamá
hola raúl la primera dama de los eeuu el
vaivén junto a su hija se lee vaivén e
inician una gira en américa latina que
tiene previsto recorrer ecuador ya con
su segunda parada panamá que se espera
que llegue en horas del mediodía de hoy
y luego iría a costa rica en su llegada
a panamá está previsto que
sea recibida en el palacio presidencial
de las calzas por la primera dama de
panamá de yasmín colom de cortizo luego
tendrá una reunión privada e
inmediatamente la agenda está marcada
por temas sociales pues luego de esa
reunión privada para visitar una escuela
y van a revisar parte de un programa
social que realiza el despacho de la
primera dama de panamá que tiene que ver
con la atención de niños y jóvenes con
dificultades auditivas y visuales
luego de esa visita a esta escuela está
previsto que la primera dama de los eeuu
tenga una reunión con funcionarios de la
embajada de eeuu en panamá y la agenda
concluiría para el día de mañana el día
de mañana está previsto que visite
un hogar un lugar que está destinado al
cuidado y a la atención de personas con
vih
luego de este encuentro la primera dama
de los eeuu en chile bailén
culminará su visita a panamá y se
dirigirá hacia costa rica oscar también
hablemos de la importancia de esta gira
de la esposa del presidente
estadounidense por la región
si parte de esta gira recordemos está
es previa lo que va a ser la cumbre de
las américas que se va a realizar a
partir del próximo 6 de junio en la
ciudad de los ángeles en ecuador donde
está hasta el día de hoy la primera dama
de los eeuu ha tenido encuentros con el
presidente guillermo lazo está previsto
que también tenga encuentros con el
presidente rodrigo de chávez de costa
rica y ella ha resaltado la importancia
de
la importancia de la democracia y ha
criticado también a gobiernos
autoritarios de la región sin embargo en
el caso de panamá no hay en su agenda un
encuentro con el presidente de la
república
laurentino cortizo según nos informaron
de la presidencia de la república el el
presidente ya tenía compromisos y va a
estar fuera de la ciudad durante la
visita de la funcionaria de la primera
dama de los eeuu el bayern